the husband of the Southwest Airlines
passenger who was killed in last week's
mid-air explosion says that his family
has lost its bedrock
Jennifer Reardon died after one of the
plane's engines exploded the business
woman from Albuquerque New Mexico was
partially sucked out of the plane Kris
Van Cleave spoke with her husband that's
Michael Riordan he's at Albuquerque's
Airport with his story Chris good
morning good morning Jennifer Reardon
met her husband Michael when they were
teenagers in Vermont that started a
29-year love affair and those are
memories that Michael is holding on too
tightly there's some pictures that I've
saved for myself that I have around the
house that I just I hugged and kiss
every day and those are mine and I'm not
let me go
Michael Reardon is heartbroken over the
death of his wife Jennifer the love of
his life when was the last time you
talked to Jennifer before this flight
she called me that morning actually on
our way to the airport and we ended with
I love you safe travels and so to be
able to tell my beautiful bride I love
you is comforting the 43 year old Wells
Fargo vice president was flying home
from a business trip when the engine on
her Southwest flight blew the explosion
destroyed a window and Jennifer was
partially sucked out of the plane the
doctor called and said I'm sorry Michael
but we've done everything we can and we
couldn't save her and I just dropped the
phone and luckily my friend was there
too
to handle me because I was just the
depth so do you think you could go are
you angry are you left with questions
are you numb where where are you in in
this process I'm trying to keep my heart
warm with with Jennifer and make sure
that her life is respected and honored
Michael didn't want to discuss the
details of the accident or the
investigation this weekend about 2000
family friends and neighbors packed an
Albuquerque auditorium to remember
Jennifer her currency was compassion the
kind of kindness that folds like a hug
the Reardon's have two children 12
year-old Avery and Joshua who is 10 when
I look in their eyes they they
understand that mom's gonna be with us
in every decision so I think they have
some
but they have not had a chance to
understand how they grieve yet and and
how we set our new norms the Reardon's
gave out these guardian angel coins at
Jennifer's memorial Michael is carrying
one with him he says it's a reminder
that Jennifer is looking out for him and
the kids
Nora it's just heartbreaking Chris thank
you a lot of people will be looking up
from the kids I love what he said trying
to keep Jennifer his heart warm with
Jennifer and just affect the way the
family's at they're doing the service
and the kids are so young it's so hard
to watch but I'm so grateful for Michael
for sharing a story because you know he
it's a way to transfer his wife's
amazing life and you know hold it up as
an example for us which is really hard
to do obviously incident trying moment